the Joe Rogan experience I'll tell you
what man since Starbucks got in trouble
for being racist there's a lot more
homeless people at Starbucks like they
understand I think you just go it's
really it's really odd
that's so funny it kicked out they can't
get kicked everybody's afraid dude it's
it's a hundred percent different 100%
different in some spot like which ones
are you going to the ones in Hollywood
they know how to handle it for the most
part yeah their locks on everything I
went to a shifty one in downtown where
they don't even have a bathroom like how
you serving coffee you know have a
bathroom cuz it makes you [ __ ] and piss
yeah this is ridiculous but I realized
they didn't have a bathroom because the
homeless people there was homeless
people that had like this guy had a port
and he was charging all of his devices
he had everything he had like a phone a
[ __ ] iPad a long night ahead of him
but they get free electricity there and
he so he's got like a bag of his stuff
like he's got a little camp in the
corner of the Starbucks I'm like wow on
one hand like hey how's a guy supposed
to get some electricity I'm right I want
him to get back up on its feet maybe
this is the way to do it maybe it's
through that iPad uh-huh on the other
hand like hey don't give me a disease
Instagram account yesterday Street
people of Los Angeles which has got some
very interesting content is that a naked
person yes it is make a person just
change it on the stranger on the street
that was actually in San Francisco I
think I remember checking that post but
wow this has got some interesting stuff
these guys were like cookin underneath
the tree with like a live grill right
somewhere but there's a Tommy's in
Hollywood sorry good times oh and
there's always like a bunch of young
homeless people cooking in front of it
like there's a bus stop they have a lit
fire like pavement like like like fear
of the walking dead style campfire like
outside of the Tommy's on Hollywood
Boulevard like on a daily basis how
weird it's just weird that that's okay
like if you just wanted to start a fire
on the side of the road would that be
okay no but can you start a fire to cook
apparently can you or did they just not
get busted probably need a permit yeah I
think you need something like a to be
like a grill street vendor type
apartment if you want to sell
what if you just wanted to give food
away you can't do that you can't but you
can eat it yourself
I don't know can you offer it something
it seems like you could offer it to
somebody like you know if they allow you
to cook and you and I were sitting there
and we're cooking and said would you
like something and you said yeah yeah
that looks good that should be okay it's
like a donation or some places they
don't charge you to get in but they
accept a donation but what if you plan
in advance you say hey all of us meet on
the corner of 3rd in Santa Monica I'm
gonna have a cookout so we're just
setting up right here on the concrete
yeah those do people should just go to a
park that has those grills that Griffith
Park is not far right Griffith Park is
like people with homes cooked there yeah
you got free grills yeah you could just
do it up there anybody can cook there
yeah
[Applause]